foreign
it's the Thanksgiving episode the
Gratitude where we stop for a second and
just say
I'm so grateful even if I'm grateful for
just little bitty things because
everything has been a dumpster fire this
past year or I'm really struggling
because I had a picture of what
Thanksgiving was going to look like
um thanksgiving's in a day right Kelly
thanksgiving's tomorrow I sure thought I
wasn't going to be at my in-laws yet
again or I sure thought that my whole
family is going to be here or I sure
thought that my son was coming home from
college or that my daughter was going to
be out from deployment whatever it is
it's a season when we stop and we just
say despite what's happening or
um in addition to what's happening I'm
grateful I'm gonna own it for a second
you've heard me talk about this
especially in the past I haven't talked
about as much recently and I need to I
need to be more vocal about it gratitude
a practice of gratitude
minute by minute hour by hour a daily
gratitude practice an orientation
towards life
towards saying okay I didn't want this
to happen I didn't expect this to happen
I'm going to whether right now or in two
years I'm gonna find
gratitude I'm gonna say thank you
um whether it's to the firefighters who
showed up with my house burned to the
ground whether it was the people who
stood by me when my loved one passed
away whether it was
um
my wife isn't doing so well but I'm so
grateful that your wife's cancer is
healed right what I'm gonna have an
orientation towards finding Beauty
finding gratitude gratitude is one of
the most important psychological tenets
for a well life
what does that mean this gobbledygook
for
if you are not grateful if you don't
have a regular gratitude practice where
you stop and feel grateful
you are choosing to die early
you're choosing a miserable existence
and I would suggest why
why waste your life why
so there's I I wrote down four ways I've
heard it in the scientific literature
and uh in kind of the popular instagramy
literature which not really literature I
take that back in the popular instagramy
influencer nonsense
um here's four ways you can
um Express gratitude have a gratitude
practice one is just you hear this all
the time write three to five things
every day that you're grateful for keep
a journal right just have a journal that
you write them in things that you're
grateful for
I am grateful for I'm grateful for I am
grateful for just do that every day you
can do it in the morning you can do it
before you go to bed
um you can also watch somebody do great
things for somebody else
so you can
um
watch a video of somebody doing
something kind for somebody else you can
listen to a story where somebody
explains and then this guy came and
helped me out she showed up this person
pulled over on the side of the road and
helped me out when I had a flat tire you
can be in that story
a third way is you can write a letter to
somebody
I think this is
Africa I forgot the uh I need to find it
I'll put it in the show notes um he's a
psychologist at Harvard a psychology
Professor who recommends to a student's
um one of the only ways you can achieve
happiness instantaneously you can turn
the dial is to write a letter of
gratitude to somebody and then visit
with them either by phone or in person
and
um right and read it to him let him know
hey I wrote you this letter
um in all honesty I've only been able to
do that once and that was to my son it's
very hard to do to write a letter of
gratitude to your mom or to your dad I
was with some guys this weekend on a
hunting trip and one of the guys is
gonna do this for his father
um all the his father's got is is
working through some significant medical
issues and so they all wrote letters
that they're going to read
and
he had to stop the conversation because
it was it got choked up just thinking
about what he's gonna do right so it's
very hard to do that
but there's some significant
psychological healing that happens with
that and then there's another one that
that's
um that I got from Andrew huberman which
I think is phenomenal and I've had some
great success with it and it's it's
almost a meditative gratitude where I'll
turn the lights off in my basement and
I'll sit down in my normal gratitude
position if you will sitting down with
my legs out or legs folded and my back
up and I close my eyes
and I remember a moment that I'm truly
grateful for
when my dad hugged me after a thing when
my mom put her hands on my face and said
she was proud of me when my wife fill in
the blank with my son daughter filled in
the blank when I got a job and I didn't
think I was going to get it I put myself
back in that moment and it takes it can
take 60 seconds it can take three or
four minutes but I'm going to the best I
can re-experience that moment of
gratitude
that moment when I'm so grateful thank
you for showing up in my life thank you
for being there when I needed you thank
you for sitting with me when I was
grieving thank you for holding my hand
through this ugly mess thank you for
saying yes when I asked you to marry me
all these right these moments of
gratitude
um whatever it looks like for you
I challenge you from this day forward
let's do this from this day until the
new year
every day have a gratitude practice
whatever it looks like put a um put
something on your phone set an alarm and
just say gratitude practice and remind
yourself I gotta take three minutes and
write this thing down because Delaney
said to her to remember to be grateful
just do it and my promise is you will
begin to shift how you see the world it
changes the glasses by which you filter
and see the world then it's
extraordinary so very cool thing
um we reached out on social media on the
internet and I asked the people who
follow my Instagram account
um what are some things you're grateful
for would you be willing to share and we
got a bajillion responses I was hoping
for seven we got a million we got a
bunch of people saying I'm grateful for
this my dad showed up my husband's
awesome my wife is amazing my kids or
whatever okay so Kelly how many people
wrote in and told us who or what they're
grateful for we had 100 million trillion
responses yes I love John numbers
actually we had six we had six
responders
um and four of them were pets they were
the children of you dog parents out
there
it's not a thing but hey so
um we split these up so y'all pick some
of your favorite ones and so let's go
through the b double O T H and start
over there with you Jenna yes yes so um
I've got three I'm gonna read here okay
um so first one comes from traveling
cows with a k
um and they said our IVF Clinic they
helped us make our beautiful twin girls
so that's the first one um the second
one is the Adam toy said my wife for
dealing with all my anxiety and health
issues recently
and then the third one is from ape
Baldwin I am thankful for my two
brothers who have walked through the
darkest nights with me oh hey how cool
is that that who is in the middle
the Adam toy the Adam toy my wife
exacerbates my anxiety and pours
gasoline on it and his helps that's so
nice it's so great
okay who's next
Ben
uh yeah so I've got one here from I got
a few here uh first one from Red c
ardinals not Cardinals C Arnold's uh
says my friend Jason he helps me combat
Suicidal Thoughts just by talking to me
dang way to go Jason Jenny Jenn 03 says
my fifth grade students this year
they're pushing me to apply so many
different approaches to my teaching is
is that because they're so ridiculous
and out of control that she's having to
come up with new things I love it good
job fifth grade students and then uh
last one I've got is uh really really
Riley says a couple that set aside
Comfort uh Slash privacy and let me stay
with them for six months in college for
free wow so that's pretty baller that's
huge yes Kelly all right so miss
cerebell 22. I didn't know you could
feel thankful oh this isn't yours this
is somebody else okay read theirs read
theirs go ahead I just hope the people
know what I what I deal with this is
It's my job well they know what I deal
with so go ahead Miss Sarah Bell 2020
said my mother-in-law she's a prayer
Warrior and I can talk to her about
things I'm not comfortable talking to my
mom about she has always treated me like
her own daughter how many did we get
people who are grateful for their
in-laws is that the one the one the one
the one way to go America yeah
um at Anton dot fam said my father and
husband who have not to do with social
media are both incredibly supportive
loving men
and then at classical voice coaching
said my high school choir director his
belief in me taught me how to believe in
myself through my Opera career
you don't hear the words Opera and
career together very often that's
fantastic man Nate Dog what do you think
Stussy reezy says I'm thankful for my
sister she just got sober and we are
spending more time together very cool uh
of a working mom says my mom takes the
kids overnight every Friday night so my
husband and I can have a date night whoa
that sounds incredible actually yeah
yeah
uh Laura Beth says my neurologist he
saved my life and gave me an internship
as a jump start into my career wow
that's awesome uh the ones I've got are
from Corey coaster music
said my college junior varsity soccer
coach sent me on the right path and is
checked in with me for the last 10 years
you know what I love that when a teacher
or coach just reaches out I've got
students that I used to coach and teach
and I try to reach out every once in a
while
I just love it man I love seeing how
people are successful they got families
and they got careers and jobs just like
my it's my favorite thing in the world I
love it uh Skelly 9181 right my
childhood best friend no matter how far
apart we've lived she's always been a
huge support system
and Mason Dot algiere says my dad he's
always lends an ear to hear wise counsel
and is a rock to help keep me grounded
so red hey thanks to everybody for
writing in um we did we have we had an
overwhelming response it was awesome
this is important just take a minute uh
Jenna let's go through the booth real
fast
um curveball what's somebody somebody or
something you're grateful for and
besides me we all know that that's gonna
be everybody's number of course so
besides the opportunity to work with
this stable stable guy keep going yep
um so I would say I'm very thankful for
my mom
um for and I know she's listening
because she listens to the show now
um for never giving up on me through the
hardest seasons of my life and seeing
the potential in myself that I could
never see for myself at that time
that's awesome
Benjamin
I'm going to say as cliche as it is I'm
very thankful for my wife I just had a
lot of ups and downs this year we bought
a house then we had an injury and a
layoff and I just got hit by a car you
know I don't even get by a car you get
by my truck but true cool I was trying
to downplay it but uh but she's always
been there for me and is super
supportive and couldn't have gotten
through everything without her that's
awesome
um mine would be my sister my mom is in
the last days of her life due to
Alzheimer's and it's in Texas so I'm not
there and my sister's having to deal
with all that and she's been going to
the nursing home daily making sure
hospice is doing what they need to do
and just really caring for her and
taking the brunt of that and I know how
hard that is and I very much appreciate
that she's able to do that and that she
does it with love
uh and then for me I would say uh I'm
thankful for my daughter uh two years
ago she was diagnosed with a rare form
of cancer and was told that she would
have a 75 chance of it coming back and
so far she has beaten the odds that's
amazing good deal man
um and I would say
hmm
I just get kind of overwhelmed with
gratitude because my life is
um just sitting on
the gifts and talents and love and care
and forgiveness of so many people
um I would probably say I'm deeply
grateful
for Todd and fat John
for Michael
you know
Kevin for Trevor and Craig for
um
JP Nate Justin these men in my life who
aren't afraid they're some of the few
who aren't afraid to say hey that's
that's not cool that's not who you are
they're not afraid to say hey
um that joke's not funny they're not
afraid to say I know you love your wife
but you need to treat her better
um they're men that hold me accountable
they also remind me to laugh deeply they
think I vote terribly they think that
some of my politics are stupid and my
mental health advice is dumb and they
don't hesitate to let me know they also
will call and say hey
um
I don't listen to your show but I heard
one call that's what they always say
they don't listen but then they do and
that call was you did a good job you
really helped that person and so they're
not afraid to say great job too
and so
um I'm not who I am without my friends
Potts and Caleb and Ryan and Buddy and
Tucker the whole gang man I'm just so
grateful for my friends
um and then I guess at the end of the
day my best friend on planet my wife
Sheila just just people I can laugh with
and be with and hang out with and I can
only kiss one of those that's not true
because all my friends is cool all right
um so don't forget don't forget
be grateful make it a part of your life
make it a practice make it a regular
thing you do think for things think of
moments experience friendships remember
back to those times
if we all turn the dial to being more
grateful
the whole world changes and it starts
with each one of us